so i walk outside and when i walk
outside guys i'm pretty happy with
myself for a couple of reasons one i
didn't have to get as violent
as my dad did to get him this mad right
and two look whatever you all think
about it
nobody in here remembers the stories
about when you were a kid how many times
your
mom cut the crust off your sandwich you
don't remember the nice stuff
you're like you remember when [ __ ]
tommy fell off the roof do you know what
i mean
those are the stories you tell and i
know this is a story he's gonna tell
this is a memory we're gonna share and i
like that [ __ ] when he looks back he's
gonna think
man that was funny as [ __ ] right and i'm
happy
and then he comes busting out of the
house
by the way you wanna know what his fight
clothes were jean shorts
no shirt and a bandana
i was like where are you going coachella
like when the [ __ ]
and he comes running at me he throws a
punch i duck and i throw him over my hip
and bam he lands on his back
you guys know that noise with all the
air just
and i'm like oh i got a couple minutes
the wind has been knocked out of him and
the first time the wind gets knocked out
of you you think you're dying right
so i'm like oh i got at least 15 minutes
to [ __ ] with this guy 15 seconds or so
right so i'm like i'm always guys i was
a huge wrestling fan
huge randy the macho man savage fan so
i'm like i'm gonna reign in the macho
man
so i start to walk around and i'm like
oh yeah the macho man
i'm looking in the window at the camera
like
and then i get a couple more seconds i'm
gonna come off the top rope and i'm
gonna jump on him pull his leg up pin
him
end of the wedding video perfect right
so i go what you gonna do
when the macho man lands on you
that's the name is it for you know spur
of the moment that's all i had
i go to push and when i push his leg
slipped when this leg slipped
a disc popped in my back him and i
landed right on him and i knocked the
wind out of him again
and he's like get off of me get off of
me and i was like get out from under me
get out from under me
and we're both laying there like a
couple of wet mops in the front yard huh
30 seconds later he gets out from under
me he walks inside and i'm laying in the
front
and uh just laying there
probably for like 10 minutes and then
the front door opens and
i see two feet walking out to me and i
recognize their feet those are my wives
she walks out and she leans over me just
like this and she goes
how do you think that went
i said i think it went pretty well and
she said did it
i said i won she goes did you
she said all i know is that he's inside
drinking water
and you're still laying out here with
your face in the dirt
he looks like the winner i go yeah but
we're gonna cut the video off way before
that nobody's ever gonna see that [ __ ]
and i said babe and i knew why she came
out
she came out to tell me that she was
right and i was wrong and she was
and i was gonna let i told her right off
the front i said look i know
you were right and i was wrong and i'm
so sorry and i am the adult and he is
the child
and i really just need to keep that in
mind like this is how you parent
we're parent together and i'm sorry we
didn't do this together and i should
have listened to you
but thank you very much for coming out
to help me in and she said
i didn't come out here to help you with
she said i came out here to tell you
that the camera is still running in the
window
and i think i'm going to start a little
video of my own
because the sprinklers are set to come
on in three minutes
and as she's walking away i go babe i
don't think that's a good idea she turns
to me and she goes
i'll let you know when i have a bad idea
[Music]
foreign